praetor what would wheredid predator
come from space today from space I have
the answer
yeah he's an alien for sure yeah so
nailed it
yeah we yeah we set out to do the the
classic predator from the first two
movies predator wanted to and you know
with all his gadgets you know we wanted
to kind of give him everything that he's
that he's kind of had in those in those
in those movies so we should pretty much
have everything possible so obviously
noticed there is on the screen through
the variations let's start off with
warrior how about that scheme you want
to walk us through that with Nick and do
the Carl Weathers or should we wait for
that do you want to oh no we're on
practice we're in though okay we got you
got you got you are we waiting you're
doing it let's do it let's do it into
the limit
I'm very excited to have the car whether
skin involved in this when I heard we
were doing it I was very very excited
and and the voice right yeah everything
your boys all the weather's it's awesome
remember we talked about Nick it's very
important right now that we stop talking
right about now but there's no antidote
to practice so you don't oh so long
predator um hello breakdown with him is
that he has special duties like
defaulter said kind of like the cop in
special yeah just go on and stuff but
you know I pass and then each of you
variation okay so that's kind of how we
can take broken out so you know you know
it is normal lifestyle you'll have like
some of the you know weapons expir
businesses and he's got the same car
that comes out just like that yeah and
so like you know for example like that
bro and then you'll notice he has really
really good rate she write his jump to
is awesome uh Mitchell jump punch is
really good
yeah like a lot of love somebody has so
let's go over the smart disk what all
the smart disk and just kind of hangs
out there in the air let's do that so
you'll notice that he has a dizzy throws
and so will use a broom here and be able
to sit there and like hang her do you
want to bring me into little sit there
and hang for about like on like 30 40
ticks and I know what we'll do is after
pepper you'll staples out the parts are
so it has this homing property
associated and you know once it's in the
air just happy
so like you know God tries to jump in
and it's just sitting there so it's
really good I can see like you throw it
up and what's he's doing it like runny
and right and then do like a mix-up yeah
yeah it's really good for screen control
basically you put it on the screen and
then they kind of have to respect it
because if they get hit look at combo
and then if you think they're going to
block you can run and then thrower and
it really compliments as long Renate you
know you can put the Disgaea and then
come in with the back - and you can also
do the discs in air alright you can do
that in comments right and then the e^x
disk puts out two of them to distribute
then they come out so feel what you're
seeing this to being like oh my doesn't
mean this substrate at all times Anders
but go ahead and pull one out if I if he
gets jammed yeah go away it's a little
go away on here I'll go in block
I mean you can also and can you do it
exp - mom oh yeah so no little going on
hit or block the opponent doesn't have
to disrespect it I could put it on then
you can do Jacksons - punch ya in front
of it you can kind of take a risk if you
want to try to get resident then of
course predator can know that you know
that I could do stuff to beat your -
punch that's how do the guessing cool
Kenny listen what's the next shared
special so the next thing is the diss
leaping scimitar move which it was
pretty much from their personal movies
it's like directly from the scene where
you know predator no side of the tree
like runs in any grabs Carl Weathers
stabs of this so am I right in saying
that you watched a lot of credit yeah
yeah that's pretty much you monster did
you find yourself making the predator
sound from time to time have you been oh
yes that's exactly what I mean okay well
they they did not do any of the sad
recording but it's going on the Scimitar
slam you can actually control which
directly throws over the directional
input so if you will I want you out of
the corner I can throw you that way
can the X version has armor so it's like
it may be I think you're gonna shoot a
rocket right here and I can open-close
it doesn't matter I could do the
punching thing yeah these that's kind of
one of his better armoured moves to get
in yeah if you're having a hard time
getting a disc out because of their
projectile you can use it to be their
projectile and it does the ground
balance - I'm
crunch obviously you can extend your
combos with you think it's more range Oh
does it that's the look I really like
about this character is that I think you
guys really nailed the sort of ferrule
effectively becomes very it's almost
it's lumbering but in a very agile way
he's very sort of like I like to wake
this you know it's very there's an
animal team can literally enjoy and then
uh his last common very common special
is yes the this is a quote and so it's a
little different than where you would
like CL reptile yeah he's distorted so
it's kind of like a little hard
but basically what this is doing is it's
um is mitigating damage so it's like I
don't normally go alone
it'll take less to damage new last 8
seconds you'll get up to five kids and
then your way the the experts will last
for 16 seconds Sam you thinking no ship
can machine not all can be on the in
residents alike funny like Kung Lao for
example know who goes who does
subjectivity become ship damaged under
the so yeah so we got like this it's
great for 16 seconds which is you know
it's pretty surreal ain't aimin eternal
mansions are only 16 seconds long okay
usually in disability type rooms are
game usually go away on hit is does not
grow you can afford a ticket it but
it'll go with that yeah
and that's pretty much the common
between all variations you know what's
special to the warrior alright so now
we're you're some you know we're very
ation of
came up with like almost the data one
remove the mask means are reminiscent
classy first movie so select the back
yell something is done in big stuff the
Baptist apartment its burden does have
farmer
yeah yeah Nelson has a like a serial
over just like
and it all has different variation or
different distances you can do it close
yeah plus mean far yeah that was
especially kind of like and there's a
good choice to do this without the mask
because this windows cool I think the
most feral of the others one much more
technology day this is so just in your
face slice slice jump up grab it like it
to throw like that it was really great I
think this one's gonna be really good
for like a brawler tide layer because he
normally doesn't have a great overhead
he has a great low but he doesn't have a
great overhead to go with it except in
this one he does right so you can use
this is like an overhead launcher from
an armored room this is going to make
his combos even better right so I think
this will be like the in-your-face one
which in the opposite of like the
technology zoning is cool so let's go on
to the next one I forgot I forgot
something the big thing about warrior oh
what's that
what's he do yeah so he has a
interesting move something that we like
not actually before because we've done
count proximity-based moves before but
but we've never actually done one where
sometimes all the time out on it so
basically what this is
is an explosion that's gonna happen
aprender after it's like 3 X 3 seconds
which we'll do games prior velocity and
victims law so that that's actually
that's an interesting train you can get
in the grab yes
I'm gonna grab do a pop up and if you
use it properly for my god Derek key
block I like a third blocking a
wonderful right I choose not it'll still
work even when they're blocking bank or
you see when I was doing the throw or
doing it hit or even the Scimitar slam
at any time it will go off and they get
that terracotta yeah this isn't like so
many hoops anyway still like it in and
get him grab them that yes I can also
hook you out of it right and unlike the
invisibility if you hit him out of it he
will get rid of it so the metagame is
kind of being put it on and then you're
gonna be desperate to hit me out of it
right you can't afford it to sit there
and block so you're gonna have to go on
let's talk about what happens that you
take damage you use it as well as your
opponent's now at the end of the round
you're telling me earlier we're
practicing some cool [ __ ] yeah so one of
the things about this is that um get
precious and
it's also low enough and he does that
boom and lands no magic stick so got
juice yep that's and magics engines are
some of the coolest things yes we've had
three of them are being put and they're
very exciting
oh I go actually didn't know about the
whole grab into the thing yeah I'll
begin next there's a lot of it people go
fight spree using that correctly yeah I
can't wait to see the tournament cuz
imagine a predator player like no life
left and the other guy running away for
dear life it's gonna be awesome
hello cases cool cool uh you want to did
that we forgetting anything did I mess
anything up with the Derrick resume of
the film I think so alright cool ok
we'll go through next we're gonna do the
hitch kun ten right pass that on over to
Steve OTS so you'll notice one the
variation difference is he has the black
mascot right yeah I mean he the mask um
so this is variation where's the plasma
the plasma cannon and you'll notice that
of course so this is where he installs
plasma you know projectile you guys have
a whole shot a low shot and
every DX versus those you know which is
cool and he does not a special thing to
where you can actually like do the
command that's going together and then
hold it and it so you'll have this laser
that you can put on you you can just let
you like I like to get it on board where
you'll just go back to idle threat so
just like a little possum stand like the
cannon boots are just really cool been
there they can come with yeah yes to
something you can Hey
ii-i'll get there alright I'll up at
some point I'll get okay you know
hey that took me all day but I got it oh
yeah sorry the way you do some tyrant
like Jax right here no no babe this is
really cool though seeing Carl Weathers
and brother go and yeah cut it out
homicide head-to-head is it guesswork
yeah - it says I'm Stuart so that is his
sort of I guess zoning yeah pretty much
but you can also use the lasers up close
if you want you know you could do a
block string and go to the low laser if
you think they might like to apply it in
the morning
yeah cut this up there boy and he's got
some really good combo so these problems
most part yeah this definitely need to
keep out zoning players variation that's
also good for bricklayer that's true
we had for that so cool drop just end
this on a punch in the face and moving
oh oh you know what I don't think we've
done this yet all right Oh
ah awesome and you know I'm gonna say
this how I'd be out of line here this
may be the first game ever where Carl
Weathers can powerbomb the predator yeah
I think it is that's never happened
anywhere else I don't know anyone
imagined 20 years ago when making where
will combat 1 then eventually Carl
Weathers would powerbomb the predator no
we did it guys we made it letsa let's go
check out the blasts ready yep um you
want to do this inverses so we can hear
some intros maybe see anything else so
that they've got Steve you doing I know
I just wanna think you feel everything I
don't think it works pretty alright sure
them I'm gonna be Jack's 3 Cho a
commando cage - yeah ok
oh yeah they're talking no no oh the
jungle it randomly picked it how perfect
that's like it's cannon always picks
code oh yeah just
don't talk getting on my nerves
wait yeah fart yeah so here we are
oh so in this variation using this later
trap so what you do is you can put this
thing down and the lasers will come out
and they'll act like I look like
landline good so yeah I'll act like a
landline that will string up the victim
and so you can like grandma's by weight
underneath them you can you can put this
in close this mean and our do this a lot
opposite like income you think remind a
guy don't like pressure listen you can
use it in combos it actually works out
of the air as well
you can jump backward and throw down
Jose get throw it in the air as well
yeah oh yeah I'll come and know Mac and
the ex1 is instant you don't have to
wait for it to open up yeah by default
in the normal one is um takes like
really about a half second yeah yes a
second our second camera reason but yeah
I'll activate you know after sometime
but yeah what he is working on to trap
string them up you know the whole string
down thing is it's like we see that in a
movie
no pressure one you strung on topper low
lows boilers oh and also you can
detonate the trap too right yeah like
that's that's just um this is like a
little bonus there for for the traveling
you can you can detonate the trap
without even then when it doesn't even
have activated like so you can just
throw it on the ground seems like it's
alright Steve you so this would be great
defensively and offensively you know as
Nick said you can put it up there and
then they know they can't cross that
line so you can put out these middle try
to shooter project on go with the diet
or offensively you know Nick pointed out
you could do like a string and then go
into it and they're gonna have to try to
jump out or arm around you can guess
that they're gonna do that and do a
throw or and then just fun things that I
like to do like you can throw the trap
out and then upper and the land of the
draft like that oh well
Oh see ya oh alright so that happened
thank you okay thank you Steve
thank you for that that was good it was
good um let's should we just do some
matches which accreditor tweets real
quick sure oh there's one other thing
oh oh oh the heel oh yeah what's all
right um all right pick some two sides
jacks to fight the table okay
all right like me just get the onion Oh
controller was not gonna do he look at
the Jen look for when you're messed up
and go back okay oh man getting on my
nerves
yeah say well so yeah he variation does
that this
damage maybe some there you know we've
seen so yeah we like seeing him do this
movies and so we gave it to the
variation which will come like something
Prima's in the situation where you know
you maybe have a trap across the screen
you might do it yeah so you know maybe
you're low on health and youth it up
with the snag you can use that to get
some help if you come back and how much
do you get back for the PX 10px linux
10% a nice meal down blocks out by neck
oh yeah Steve earlier today you're
telling me we're going to lunch that you
have a combo where you want to check
yeah I need to borrow you do you have a
2 bar 38 percent is that about nothing
like that okay use that face I can do
this on my first try I do I have what
you don't they're from alright we're
gonna see it
ah drop the last it's good though it was
good like together and you know what
funny
everyone always says and I dropped my
combo guess what there's a new comp over
town
I think I'd have to drop about 100 more
to Matt you Oh shots fired
that's right yes that's me look here
some predator Manchus about that I mean
what's that I'm having a matches I don't
we should do a fig Natalie oh yeah
predator wins fatality just a little off
the top ah good good because he took
part again I go Hey
you